what your mother is on her way here a
rider she's less than an hour
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my gosh
oh my dear one
sorry i just needed your mother and
found an empty space
come the space is empty no more
now young lady
there is a rumor sweeping europe that
you have taken russia from your husband
god yes empress who's the leader of
russia you are empress
hazard
what is hazar huzzah it's
a lot of things all purposes variously
also you notice are you pregnant i hoped
that's what it was russians can be quite
part
i had feared you turned native for a
mother who set her heart on marrying her
four daughters
to kings of europe
and no one would believe it when i said
i would they thought it madness but you
always saw it and then to have done it
and for the final one to be france
the jewel of europe
and then
and then
and then
you
overthrew your husband
and the deal was off
no one wants to risk a rebellion from
inside the marriage bed
sorry
speechless
[ __ ]
either would be fabulous both would be
appropriate
sorry
you are who you are
always were
and i love you for your
crazy mind and willful ways
but you have cost your sister greatly
with this
whim this is not a whim
it is my destiny we were talking of your
sister
yes i'm sorry yes
i will have to make a new plan
it will be difficult now i do not wish
us to misunderstand each other i love
your daughter i am on her side i thought
you were on russia's side they are the
same
she is russia
she is a child
with a dazzling intelligence and a
dizzying belief in the power of herself
and if she is being duped into using
these to put herself in grave danger at
the behest of others
then those people are no friends of mine
i assure you i am sure you do
oh
poor sergey
he is unwell
i don't find you intermittable
[Music]
[Music]
are you all right i'm mortified
i thought that was it for a moment i
thought you'd kill me don't say that i'm
sorry
i need to rest though
but
there's a list
of everyone you should kill
mother
they fought for me you don't know what
they fought for
it's funny i was just thinking
sometimes i
miss my mother
her being dead at an early age and
sometimes i'm glad she's dead as i have
lived my own life
on my own terms
subtle what are you
we have some concerns
seeing you with your mother you are
not quite yourself we worry what she
does to you you can beside love me
beyond any human on this earth
care for me and my sisters like we are
precious gems make a home for us and
ignite a fire in us to be the special
ones we are
she she perhaps does not understand us
is our point we worry she wants us dead
oh she did give me a list and you were
on it
oh
i'm first
oh relax
she has always wanted people dead for
months once she plotted the death of our
neighbor hess i see it i'd done it in a
way she found disturbing
we would gather round with tea and
kugelhop
and we would all have to think of ways
we could kill him and get away with it
fun game
we just played chess
ladies you may all go but i thank you
for the insight into your lives
it has inspired me why are you getting
up i need paper darling
what are you doing
she has that look
what do you need i will set up in here
muriel get me the current legal codes
regarding women and what are you talking
about
think of it
a woman with the right to divorce a man
think of the freedom that would give
women who suffer violence drunkenness
men rutting on them while sweating and
smelling of cheese
it would change the very dynamics
between men and women
also women has property that must stop
you must stop this it is a delirium is
that not exciting to change the systems
women live by take power from men and
give it to us it is easy to take power
from men and sometimes they even enjoy
it but what you must not do is advertise
about it but then their fists come out
someone tried to kill you darling i'm
dealing with it
it's part of the job and you will die
if we don't change the game
and we can
what
in three days time
you will have this baby
and there is a natural pause
you
transition
out of power and into motherhood
and peter transitions back in
and it can be addressed through europe
as some strange rumor
and i can get your sister the french job
back
what
we can all be just as i planned
and
you can be safe
darling
you can play that boy
we both can
trust me
you're staring at me blankly
i'm just a piece in your perfect tableau
the maestro of marriage
you were born to be a royal wife
you were trained to be a royal wife
be one
and stop this
and live
darling your sisters can do it why can't
you
because i am not them
i'm better
oh
see it's crazy statements like that that
make me worry about your mental state
recognize who and what i am
or leave
recognize that you are mad
and you need help
and i am here to give it
get out of my palace catherine get out
of my country
go
chew
little cat
chew chew chew
but i will not stick around while you
joke
[Music]
you